alors l'Ukraine affirme avoir abattu ses
missiles supersonique l'année dernière
les missiles pourtant présenté par
Moscou comme quasiment impossible à
intercepter le Kremlin a démenti
l'information alors c'est toujours qui
dit vrai quand on parle de ces choses-là
mais son attaque a été lancé alors que
le président cruien poursuit une tournée
a fait une tournée européenne pour
demander davantage de soutien militaire
puissante peut-être avoir fait des gains
là-dessus je fais le point j'ai fait le
point plutôt avec Tatiana Olga Cova
journaliste et responsables du
département international à l'Ukraine
Media Center
bonsoir Tatiana bienvenue 24 60
bonsoir cette guerre se poursuit avec de
nouvelles attaques russes qu'elle a été
l'ampleur de la TAQ et de la résistance
ukrainienne ces dernières heures
en fait l'attaque de cette nuit était
particulièrement dans ses puissants il y
avait 18 missiles dont quelques missiles
balistiques du type King Charles de ce
type qui ont été envoyés vers la capital
ukrainienne on était réveillé par les
détonations qui étaient extrêmement
fortes dans toutes les quartiers de kif
carrément étant donné que nous nous
sommes un peu éloignés à l'est et même
malgré cela nous étions carrément
réveillé par les frappes donc le matin
nous avons appris que la totalité de
missiles y compris des missiles de
balistique et les drones aussi ont été
abattus par notre défense aérienne de
quoi se réjouir mais c'est vrai que ça
fait plusieurs jours qu'on nous dérange
presque pas parce que c'est la huitième
attaque contre la capitale depuis le
début de ce mois donc qui voilà qui ne
fait que deux semaines donc minuit sans
sommeil avec voilà le fait d'être
réveillé comme ça à 3h du matin ça
commence à peser sur les habitants de
Gif mais bien sûr à la fois on est on
est très heureux de voir que la
quasi-totalité de ces attaques ont été
repoussés par les forces aériennes de
l'Ukraine avec donc des armes de défense
dites moi on est à quelques heures de la
visite d'un émissaire chinois au terme
d'une visite européenne enfin qui est
allée dans plusieurs pays même les
rencontrent pas on va y revenir dans un
instant mais qu'attendez-vous de cet
émissaire chinois
on voit que le shink continue son jeu
son jeu diplomatique qui consiste à
essayer de proposer une formule du paix
qui voilà qui est propre à la Chine mais
qui visiblement n'est pas très accepté
par le président craignant pour le
pouvoir en Ukraine notamment par les
citoyens ukraignants c'est un plan de
paix qui est très contradictoire mais à
la fois suite à cet entretien
téléphonique entre Zelinski leaders
chinois on peut espérer que en tout cas
que la Chine ne va pas aider non plus à
la Russie et ne va pas chercher à
prolonger à le trans de cette guerre qui
pèse trop leur demande sur les épaules
des citoyens ukraignants donc c'est ça
l'espoir surtout qu'il y aura pas
d'envoi d'armes chinoise à la Russie
quant à cet effort diplomatique bien sûr
il y aura le temps pour la diplomatie
mais ce n'est pas maintenant il faut il
faudrait d'abord repousser encore plus
les troupes russes et puis de essayer
créer un contexte propre pour les
négociations pour l'instant l'agresseur
n'a pas renoncé à son plan initial qui
consiste à raser en fait l'Ukraine de la
carte de l'Europe rasé au sens très très
propre de ce terme donc et donc il n'y a
pas de négociation dans les médias en
même temps le président Zelinski bon a
pris la parole au Conseil de l'Europe
aujourd'hui au terme de sa tournée dans
différents pistes d'abord assez risqué
pour lui j'imagine de quitter l'Ukraine
comme ça de se promener d'un pays à
l'autre mais hier il était au
Royaume-Uni pourquoi comprendre que le
Royaume-Uni les Pays-Bas veulent en tout
cas créer ensemble créer une coalition
internationale ce serait leur initiative
pour livrer des avions de combat des
F-16 à l'Ukraine ce qui n'a jamais été
obtenue jusqu'à maintenant
ce serait bien accueilli ce serait
important comme décision pour vous cette
aide oui c'est la livraison de deux
avions de en bas pour être décisif pour
les sous de cette guerre c'est vrai que
pour l'immers zilinski avait annoncé que
en deux objectifs des sovoyages en
Europe qui comprend Rome Berlin Paris
Londres était justement de créer cette
coalition pour les avions de combat hier
encore les annonces étaient plutôt
pessimistes puisque c'est uniquement à
Londres que nous avons entendu parler
des entraînements des pilotes et non pas
de avions de combat en tant que tels qui
seront livrés les Anglais ont bien
expliqué qu'ils pour ne peuvent pas
livrer les avions qui n'ont pas
justement parce que dispo de dispose pas
de ses avions du type F16 dont l'Ukraine
a besoin mais à la fois comme c'était
annoncé par notre ministre des Affaires
étrangères rien que les écoles par les
pilotes ça veut dire qu'on approche
cette décision qui serait politique que
de livrer à fond à l'Ukraine les avions
de Copa parce que ça sert à rien de
traîner les pilotes si on a un visage
pas dans un futur assez approche ou un
moyen terme de livrer les avions de
combat c'est une question qui serait
adressée à nos partenaires américains
tout d'abord donc tout ceci sera à venir
et les avions de combat bien sûr ils
sont très nécessaire pour la contrefa
ici pour protéger les troupes
ukrainiennes qui vont progresser au sol
pour les protéger des frappes aériennes
parmi cils de type différents de la
Russie donc tout ceci pourra sauver
sauver pas mal de vie des soldats et
craignant et donc je tiens à rappeler
que que l'Ukraine avait déjà
malheureusement payé un prix extrêmement
élevé pour continuer cette guerre en
termes de vie humaine en termes de vie
de nos soldats et qui parle de guerre
parle de grands traumatismes le
président Macron aujourd'hui a évoqué
l'idée de créer une centaine de centres
d'aide en santé mentale pour aider le
peuple
ukrainien à guérir ces traumatismes
c'est intéressant
oui c'est vrai c'est vraiment aussi très
publicité par la population civile qui
en dépendamment où on habite on habite à
l'est ou à l'ouest au centre on subit
tous même nous il est civils des
conséquences de la guerre il y a des
enfants qui ont des se réveillent la
nuit en pleurant puisque ils ont peur de
cette frappes qui sont justement partout
dans le pays il y a énormément de gens
qui ont perdu déjà leurs proches lors de
cette guerre à leur mari leur fils leur
père aussi tout se traumatisme de la
perte d'un proche mais elle est très
présente physiquement il pèse lourdement
sur la population il y a aussi les
traumatismes de voilà de de perte de
travail de perte de la maison il y a 20%
de traiteur ukrainien qui littéralement
ravagé par la guerre il s'agit de des
maisons détruites des appartements
détruits il s'agit de monde détruits des
mondes humains qui sont détruits tout
ceci c'est un traumatisme qui a guérir
on a aucun doute que ça va prendre une
génération voilà à guérir les traumas
que déjà la population avait subi donc
les centres proposés par Emmanuel Macron
soit vraiment très très utile seront
très utiles pour les Ukrainiens alors
merci beaucoup Tatiana d'avoir commenté
les dernières nouvelles concernant cette
guerre qui n'en finit plus merci
beaucoup et encore une fois courage à
vous et à vos proches à voir cette
semaine au revoir
les 46 chefs d'États membres du Conseil
de l'Europe se sont rassemblés en
Islande avec AVIC aujourd'hui pour se
montrer unif face à la Russie ils ont
discuté de l'aide à l'Ukraine et des
moyens pour rendre la réussite
criminellement responsable de sa guerre
et de la destruction qu'elle engendre je
fais le point avec Frédéric Meyrin
directeur du département de sciences
politiques à l'Université de Montréal
alors bonsoir Frédéric bérand bienvenue
alors c'est un grand déploiement à 46
chefs d'État monsieur zelency était en
visioconférence c'était de retour donc à
Kiev l'importance de cette rencontre et
le message qu'on doit retenir oui on
entend pas souvent parler de du Conseil
de l'Europe c'est seulement le quatrième
sommet depuis sa fondation 1949 ce n'est
pas l'Union européenne c'est une
organisation qui est aussi en Europe
mais qui est plus large par exemple
l'Ukraine en est membre la Russie en a
déjà été membre avant d'être exclu et
normalement c'est une organisation qui
se fonde surtout sur son action
culturelle et juridique puisque elle
gère notamment la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme là on la louer un rôle
politique un rôle diplomatique c'est
l'occasion pour les chefs d'État de
gouvernement d'un groupe beaucoup plus
large que l'Union européenne et le temps
de montrer leur unité et leur soutien à
la cause ukrainienne en même temps on
apprenait que le Royaume-Uni les
Pays-Bas se préparer à créer une grande
coalition internationale pour
ultimement fournir les fameuses avions
de combat les fameux F16 est-ce que
c'est un pas en avant qui s'est confirmé
à ce conseil alors ça fait partie d'une
tournée plus large que zelinsky a mené
en Europe que la monnaie en Italie en
Allemagne en France au Royaume-Uni à
Reykjavik il était en visioconférence et
il cherche effectivement à obtenir des
engagements plus forts c'est dans la
lancée de ce qu'on voit depuis un an
finalement où les européens s'engagent
toujours davantage là il y a deux enjeux
importants
d'une part il y a des armes offensives
plus importantes donc les fameux F16
c'est un avion de chasse qui est un peu
daté déjà mais que les Ukrainiens savent
côté il y a plusieurs pays européens et
non européens qui en ont pensé à la
Turquie la Grèce les Pays-Bas et donc
les Néerlandais et les Britanniques
veulent créer une coalition encourager
le plus des tamans possible à offrir des
F16 à l'Ukraine il y a beaucoup de F16
en circulation en Europe et ailleurs et
l'autre enjeu c'est aussi le Royaume-Uni
qui a offert pour la première fois des
missiles de croisière des missiles
scalpes à l'Ukraine donc ça lui permet
d'être plus offensif mais une dimension
défensive aussi et leurs zeninski obtenu
de la part de la France et de
l'Allemagne par exemple davantage de
système anti-aériens davantage de
blindés davantage de char d'assaut
s'attaquait au système patriotes
aérien et que
Moscou dit avoir réussi d'avoir tous ces
sites parce que c'est possible ça je
sais pas si les ont réussi leurs
objectifs aujourd'hui mais ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il y a deux il y a deux
éléments il y en a un premier c'est que
la Russie pylône bombarde constamment
l'Ukraine donc elle a besoin de défense
anti-aérien ça ça fait partie de ce que
les Ukrainiens vont obtenir mais il y a
aussi la contre-offensive qui se prépare
pour reconquérir le territoire ukrainien
et là l'Ukraine a besoin d'armes
offensives d'où l'idée df16 d'où l'idée
des missiles de croisière
les fameuses avions quand on en parlait
déjà il y a plusieurs plusieurs mois les
experts dont vous peut-être disait mais
c'est un pas difficile à franchir parce
que là pour le temps en tout cas sont
fournis des des avions de combat c'est
un autre message
avec vous sur ce plateau il y a un an je
disais les avions de chasse à mon avis
ça n'arrivera jamais puisqu'ils ont
effectivement une portée offensive et la
Russie le prendrait très mal mais sa
voix ça montre à quel point les lignes
ont bougé alors évidemment tous les
alliés disent aux Ukrainiens et les
Ukrainiens s'engagent à n'utiliser par
exemple ces avions de chasse que dans le
cadre de la défense de leur territoire
de leur ciel de leur ciel national et
non pas pour intervenir sur le
territoire russe par exemple mais
comment ça serait interprété ou la
Crimée
comme une attaque sur ce qui leur
appartient depuis 2014 mais qui en droit
international fait partie du territoire
ukrainien
registre international des dommages
causés par l'agression de la Russie tout
à fait dans le mandat du Conseil de
l'Europe ça veut dire oui en effet
donc effectivement il y a la question du
dommage matériel et des dommages humains
et là on est tout à fait dans le mandat
du Conseil de l'Europe il est certain
que un jour il y aura des responsables
russes qui seront poursuivis évidemment
aussi devant la Cour pénale
internationale mais là entre temps il
s'agit surtout des dommages matériels
c'est à dire que les villes ça a été
rappelé par la journaliste ont été rasés
par les Russes et il faudra les
reconstruire il y a toute la question
aussi du patrimoine de l'humanité qui
existe en Ukraine qui dépend lui de
l'UNESCO donc il y a toute une action
qui va être menée pour d'une part
essayer de protéger ce qui peut encore
l'être des attaques russes mais aussi il
faudra reconstruire tout ce patrimoine
tous ces villes et aussi c'est c'est
société qui ont été détruites par
l'invasion de la Russie c'est le grand
suspense quand aura lieu cette
contre-offensive avec quelle force
quelle puissance avec quelle conviction
l'Ukraine peut-elle l'entreprendre
d'après vous on est dans le brouillard
de la guerre évidemment l'Ukraine n'a
aucun intérêt à annoncer à l'avance ou
et quand elle va intervenir tout le
monde s'attend à ce qu'elle le fasse
mais ça fait partie de l'incertitude qui
qui plane pour l'instant on voit surtout
ce qui se passe à barmouth qui ne ville
plutôt contrôlée par les Russes mais où
les les conflits les combats pardon sont
très très violents alors qu'il ne reste
pas risque plus personne dans la ville
et donc on s'attend toujours à ce que
dans les semaines qui viennent il y a
cette fameuse contraintive et personne
ne sait qu'elle sera le résultat est-ce
que j'ai l'inscris obtenu ce qu'il
fallait pour mener cette contrepensive à
dire mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
derniers jours ont plutôt été à sa
satisfaction selon ses propres
directe de vous parler merci d'être
patient studio
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI